[Applause]
[Music]
the conflicts between Israel and
Palestine is one of the most complicated
in international politics and as you
will probably know it's one of the most
controversial political situations in
the entire world well in order to make
it easier in this video we're going to
tackle the very delicate issue of the
Israeli settlements in the West Bank and
this is a pretty major issue because
almost all countries find these
settlements to be a serious violation of
international law in the last 40 years
all of the administration's in the
United States have taken a position
against them and when I say them I do
mean all of them and yes this matter has
compromised the special relationship
that exists between the US and Israel
and I'm not talking about governments
like Jimmy Carter's here not at all
indeed Ronald Reagan himself demanded
the immediate freeze of any new
settlements as he claims they were an
evident obstacle to peace George HW Bush
threatened to take disciplinary measures
of an economic nature and then Bill
Clinton proposed a law to punish Israel
by reducing American assistance even
today at trumps administration has asked
Israel to stop being such a pain in the
ass about it since taking office in
January Trump has publicly asked
Netanyahu to constrain sodomy
construction but has not condemned it
the State Department has said that it is
not helpful to the peace process so what
do you think Israel has done in the face
of all this criticism well they have
basically ignored it and have kept
expanding their settlements but okay now
we are here you might be wondering what
are these settlements and what do they
really mean well let's have a look at
that
[Music]
settlers and settlements the first thing
we need to know is that according to
agreements that have been reached the
territory your state of Palestine is
formed by what is today known as the
West Bank and the Gaza Strip these
territories corresponds to the political
map prior to the six-day war after which
Israel occupied these territories which
used to belong to Jordan
so the settlements they are essentially
communities villages towns and cities
that Israel has been building since 1970
in the West Bank territory of the future
Palestinian state and it is not just a
few houses we're talking about here the
West Bank is a small territory at barely
5,600 square kilometers which is about
the size of the state of Delaware but
even so and this is not considering East
Jerusalem there are 131 settlements and
furthermore there are an additional and
ninety seven outposts these outposts
they are settlements as well but in
these cases these settlements are
illegal even under Israeli law these
outposts they were built without the
consents of the Israeli government that
means that there are more than 228
Israeli settlements around the West Bank
many are in places of relevant value
like aquifers and that makes it more
complicated because roads and
infrastructure need to be set up in
order to connect them besides Israel
needs to protect these settlements and
that involves police patrolling around
the West Bank which effects the mobility
of Palestinians and makes economic
development even more difficult
and the problem isn't just the existence
of the settlements it's that they don't
stop growing in the last year more than
2000 new buildings have started to be
constructed and there are plans to build
3000 more in the next year alone
obviously in addition to this there are
also medical centers schools synagogues
etc so what's the result of all of this
well take a look at this chart to see
how the population has evolved so now
you might be asking well what's the
problem here those who are Pro
settlements claim these population
centers are growing where they used to
be nothing consider what the mayor of
male Adam says about one of the main
settlements we didn't steal the land
from anybody it was built on empty hills
you can see there the desert rocks and
sand now you have a living City been a
cash real mayor of male adumim male Adam
is the city of forty thousand
inhabitants with schools kindergartens a
theater a library an industrial center
according to the residents there it's a
complete City all right again so what
exactly is the problem the problem is
that in order to solve the
israel-palestine conflict all parties
agree the two states are necessary
one being Israel and to being Palestine
but with all the settlements Palestinian
sovereignty in the West Bank will be in
serious danger because Israel has
already said they will never give up
sovereignty over these places and that
includes the roads the infrastructure
the security controls let's be clear
Palestine will be unable to become an
effective and autonomous state with such
limitations especially considering these
settlements won't stop growing
settlements are illegal under
international law and present one of the
main impediments to peace Nikolay
Mladenov United Nations envoy on Middle
East peace
so now you can probably understand why
this topic makes everyone so tense
more and more attention attention over
Netanyahu's settlement policy hasn't
stopped growing since 2015 the situation
has reached a point that on the 23rd of
December 2016 the UN Security Council
passed resolution 23 34 that strongly
condemns the Israeli settlement policy
the Security Council reaffirms that the
establishment by Israel of settlements
in the Palestinian territory occupied
since 1967
including East Jerusalem has no legal
validity and constitutes a flagrant
violation under international law and a
major obstacle to the achievement of a
two-state solution and adjust lasting
and comprehensive peace resolution to
334 of the Security Council this
resolution could be passed because for
the first time the US didn't use their
right to veto the resolution as well
this is something that made Netanyahu's
government's really furious the Prime
Minister didn't hesitate in describing
the situation as absurd even accused
Barack Obama's administration in public
of tried to carry out a shameful anti
Israeli maneuver so yeah he was pretty
angry but this resolution shouldn't have
taken Netanyahu by surprise given some
of the decisions he announced in 2016
and confirmed in 2017
the Israeli government has started a new
settlement in the West Bank which is the
first for two decades so Israel not only
has decided to encourage the existing
settlements but they've even started a
new one on the other hands maybe
empowered by the alleged good relations
with Trump the Parliament in Israel
after lots of controversy finally passed
a new law in the beginning of 2017
this law legalizes around 4,000 houses
built on Palestinian private property
houses that the Israeli Supreme Court
had even ordered to be dismantled the
rules of the game have changed with
donald trump's arrivals president we no
longer have our hands tied as we did in
the time of Barack Obama
now we could finally build ante as we
said before the fact that Trump might
look closer to Israel doesn't mean that
his administration isn't also tired of
this settlement issue that is why I'm in
order to regain Trump's favor Jerusalem
is committed to starting a new policy
that seems to slow down the growth of
existing settlements and forbid outposts
completely but the new policy it's so
cryptic and complicated that it seems
very likely these settlements they'll
just keep growing and now you probably
have another question which is why do
these settlements why they grow so much
well pay close attention here
the inexplicable policy thing why do so
many Israelis want to live in these
conflict zones is it because maybe there
are some valuable natural resources to
be exploited well not really the
explanation it's much less creative the
government of Israel is subsidizing the
establishment of these settlements
that's right the government in Israel Co
finances the construction of houses
creating discounts of almost 70 percent
for the price of land and offers a great
deal of financial aid and you know the
result is well houses are 40 percent
cheaper than in the formal territory of
Israel and well that's not all the
government of Israel also ensures
security and provides all kinds of
public services so as you can imagine
the youth then as many families see
these as places where they can have a
better life than they could in Israel's
formal territory so now the question
becomes well how does Israel itself
benefit from this well the truth is they
really don't send an exchange they get
just a bunch of political and economic
problems these settlements aren't just
an obstacle for the peace process and
foreign policy they are also a big waste
of public money so look with the
subsidies the security the expense of
public services peace now Foundation and
the adverse center both Israeli by the
way estimate that the cost of these is
more than a billion dollars a year in
other words this is nothing there's an
expensive policy both for the citizens
of Palestine as well as those of Israel
[Music]
don't get fooled
but let me be absolutely clear Israel is
a country full of positive things unlike
that neighboring countries Israel is a
consolidated democracy with strong civil
liberties and a prosperous and
innovative economy many of the products
and services we use every day wouldn't
exist if it weren't for the technology
developed in Israel and don't be fools
putting an end to these settlements
wouldn't mean an end to the conflicts
because there is a precedent in 2005
Israel left the Gaza Strip completely
stopping all the settlements and
removing all civilians and soldiers and
the result was neither peace nor
prosperity the strip is now controlled
by Hamas radicals and it is even in
conflict with the government Palestine
itself and the situation isn't good from
a humanitarian perspective but it
definitely doesn't justify the
settlement policy of Israel and their
lack of commitment towards the peace
agreements and so now the question is is
there really any possible solution to
this conflict well more and more experts
claim the solution needs to be a
bottom-up strategy that is to say
encourage economic development in the
West Bank establish a dialogue and
understanding where trade relations
between Israelis and Palestinians and
normal and let's the national
authorities in Palestine have more
jurisdiction these they will require
time but more than that they require
commitments as it now is your turn what
do you think should happen with the
settlements well please do leave your
answer in the comments below as well as
in this survey and also don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos just like this every Monday and
Thursday and do check out our friends of
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]